[موسيقى]
يجب التاكيد على ان هذه القضيه هي مفصل من
مفاصل تاريخ القضيه
الفلسطينيه لانها تقاضي اسرائيل بجريمه
خطيره جدا حتى انها تسم
ام الجرائم وهي الاباده الجماعيه وتحركت
فيها جنوب افريقيا ضد اسرائيل وهي كتبت
بمهنيه وحرفيه عاليه وتتضمن شقين الشق
الاول هو الطلب من المحكمه بامر اسرائيل
بالتوقف عن القصف والسماح بدخول المعونات
الطبيه
والغذائيه و السماح للمهجرين بالعوده الى
اخره وهذا الطلب يسمى طلب اجراء وقتي يعني
لا يمس اساس النزاع في الدعوه بمعنى انه
اذا صدر المحكمه لصالح جنوب افريقيا في
هذا الشق لا يعني ان جنوب افريقيا كسبت
الدعوه الموضوعيه وهي الخاصه باصل النزاع
هل ترتكب اسرائيل جرائم اباده ام لا والشق
الثان ان من الدعوه هو الذي يتعلق بموضوع
الدعوه الاساسي والسؤال المطروح على
المحكمه هو هل ترتكب اسرائيل جرائم اباده
جماعيه بحق شعبنا في غزه ام
لا الشق الاول هي الجلسه التي سوف تعقد
الخميس والجمعه يومين بعدين المحكمه سوف
تصدر قرار اما سلبا او ايجابا وعاده ما
يكون القرار
في فتره قريبه جدا بسبب ان الاحداث التي
تجري الان في غزه ترتكب
يوميا وفيها مخاطر كبيره على السكان
[موسيقى]
والناس استغرب ان المحكمه لا تجد من
الاسباب ما يؤيد قرارها
بامر اسرائيل بوقف هذه المحرقه لانها
بالفعل انا في نظري انها محرقه بكل معنى
الكلمه مسؤولين اسرائيليين قالوا لن تكون
غزه مكانا امنا للفلسطينيين وهذا تصريح من
تصريحاتهم العديده يعني التي تؤيد انه
الطلب من المحكمه سيكون طلب ذو ارضيه
جيده
من غير اللائق لدوله بمستوى الولايات
المتحده ان تعلق
سلفا على اجراءات قضائيه امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه هذا لا
يليق ثانيا على الولايات المتحده ان
تحترم نشاطها هي في خلق هيئه الامم
المتحده التي خلقت
المحكمه وثالثا لا يمكن لاي مسؤول في
الولايات المتحده ان يطعن وينال من
مصداقيه هذهه المحكمه حتى في القضيه التي
حكم فيها على الامريكا في قضيه نيكارجوا
[موسيقى]
اي قرار يصدر عدل محكمه العدل ل الدوليه
ولا سما في هذه الدعوه هو قرار ملزم للدول
الاطراف التي تمثل في
الدعوه ولذلك اسرائيل وقعت على هذه
المعاهده معاهده منع الاباده الجماعيه منذ
ال 49
1949 هي كانت من اوائل الدول التي وقعت
على هذه المعاهده ووقعت
عليها في ظل
الاباده الذي تعرض لها اليهود والاقليات
الاخرى في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وبالتالي سيكون من غير المقبول
اخلاقيا
وقانونيا ومن جهه الراي العام انه اسرائيل
وقعت على هذه المعاهده في البدايات والان
تتنكر
[موسيقى]
له
اذا لم تلتزم مع ذلك في هناك اجراءات اخرى
يمكن اللجوء الى مجلس الامن الدولي لحمل
اسرائيل على
احترام هذا القرار باعتبار انه يصدر عن
اعلى هيئه قضائيه في العالم ويصدر عن هيئه
منبثقه عن هيئه الامم المتحده
ايضا وعلى فرض انه مجلس الامن لم يتخذ
الاجراء او لم تن
اسرائيل الى طلب مجلس الامن
الدولي تستطيع جنوب افريقيا ان تلجا الى
الجمعيه
العامه وتطلب من الجمعيه العامه فرض
عقوبات على اسرائيل وتحض الدول على مقاطعه
اسرائيل
دبلوماسيا اقتصاديا
[موسيقى]
علميا هارون
من اكثر القضاه الاسرائيليين
الليبراليه
لكن من اهم مواصفات براك ومن يقرا
القرارات التي اصدرها
براك تدركي انه يتحدث
ليبراليا
ويحكم بتمييز عنصري
قاس